s'étant défait des nouvelles générations
de consoles de jeux vidéo s'apprête à
envahir les salons parmi elles la xbox
one ou encore la playstation 4
et parallèlement à ça il ya le jeu sur
demande qui fait son apparition ce une
nouvelle manière de jouer qui pourrait
révolutionner le gendre la compagnie
nvidia lançait d'ailleurs il ya quelques
semaines la mise en ligne de son service
reid
on sent matthews en ces lieux par les
humains qu il y aura des jeux vidéo
d'abord qu'est-ce comment est-ce qu'on
définit le jugement demande mais c'est
un peu l'équivalent de netflix pour la
vidéo donc une aide sur netflix on
regarde un film à partir d'un serveur
distant mais le jeu sur demande c'est à
dire qu'il n'y a plus de puissance de
calcul dans la console en tant que tel
ce sont des serveurs à distance qui vous
envoient l'information des jeux auxquels
vous jouez donc en principe plus besoin
d'avoir un ordinateur très très puissant
pour jouer juste une très très bonne
connexion à internet est ce que ça veut
dire c'est la fin de la matérialité des
jeux donc plus de cassettes plus de dvd
ou de blu-ray qu'on insère dans des
consoles tout est fait dans des serveurs
distants
bon alors ça existait déjà et le jus sur
demande qu'est-ce qui vient de changer
vraiment effectivement depuis 2010 ce
type de jeu là existent mais là il ya
des gros joueurs qui arrivent via
playstation a évidemment il ya nvidia
donc est une compagnie qui fait des
microprocesseurs des cartes graphiques
compagnie extrêmement reconnu et qui se
lance donc dans ce service là avec une
tablette qui est optimisé la câble est
la tablette schild alors on promet
beaucoup avec ça d'ailleurs le catalogue
de jeux déjà disponibles est assez
impressionnant donc en fait une façon
d'élargir la base d'adeptes parce que
c'est plus économique absolument parce
qu'on n'a plus besoin d'un ordinateur la
2000 $ ou une console à 5 600 dollars
pour jouer à des jeux vidéo en principe
vous avez un simple petit téléphone il
pouvait jouer à des jeux extrêmement
complexe parce qu'il faut le redire
le calcul est fait à distance donc tout
ce que ça prend une très très bonne une
très très bonne connexion était donc
beaucoup davantage mais des
inconvénients aux six images et les non
blancs des cons veniant parce que
justement ça prend une bonne connexion
internet donc si par exemple vous êtes
dans un endroit où c'est très
congestionné
ben vote je vais être extrêmement
saccadé les jeux aussi sont de plus en
plus complexe alors la puissance de
calcul demande est énorme et les paquets
de données qu'on envoie aussi sont
énormes
autre chose les jeux ne vous
appartiennent plus auparavant on allait
au magasin alors on peut encore le faire
on va s'acheter un jeu il nous
appartient on peut jouer tant qu'on veut
si la compagnie par exemple dans un
mouvement de jeux vidéo sur demande des
sites qu'il ya un jeu qui n'est plus
important pour elle elle le retire et
c'est fini vous ne pouvez plus jouer
jamais et l'autre chose c'est que dans
le monde du jeu vidéo il ya beaucoup de
on aime beaucoup les archives on veut
joie des vieux juste extrêmement
populaire on va encore des cassettes des
premiers des premières consoles nintendo
mais dans le monde du jeu vidéo sur
demande c'est fini son dock c'est même
manière de concevoir le jeu qui est très
nouvelle
autre gros problème il peut arriver que
vous payez pour un jeu et que les
serveurs de la compagnie ne fonctionne
pas donc il ya un moment où vous voulez
jouer un jeu vidéo vous avez payé pour
ce jules serveurs fonctionnent pas mais
vous ne pouvez pas jouer une chose qui
n'arrive jamais avec les consoles
traditionnelles parce que vous achetez
un jeu vous mettez le disent dans votre
dans votre console et ça vous appartient
c'est à vous donc c'est très populaire
pour le moment des analystes estiment
qu'on pourrait passer de 30 à 150
millions de joueurs abonnés à ce type de
jeu d'ici la prochaine année
donc est-ce que ça sonne le glas des
consoles traditionnelles mais c'est ce
qu'on va voir au cours des prochaines
années
alors on vous souhaite quoi moi je me
souhaite des cassettes pour et des dvd
pour encore longtemps
merci céline bosser au revoir